près de 2 mois après la signature de
l'accord interprofessionnel le syndicat
CGT appelle au rassemblement devant le
siège d'Alcatel Lucent avant la
manifestation parisienne selon eux ce
texte augmente la précarité des salariés
ce ne sont pas des améliorations pour
les salariés mais des améliorations pour
les patrons pour licencier plus
facilement et en plus pour limiter les
recours possible du salarié face à un
licenciement qui pourrait être abusif
manifestants attendent le soutien des
parlementaires ivelinois pour que le
texte ne soit pas voté en l'état faute
de quoi la CGT a laissé entendre
d'éventuelles poursuites devant les
juridictions international de son côté
le gouvernement a fait savoir qu'il ne
souhaitait pas l'amender ce mercredi le
projet sera présenté en Conseil des
ministres avant d'être débattu à
l'Assemblée national d'ici à un mois à
la personne